hi guys I'm Eric Voss and Marvel's Black
Panther gave us everything we wanted
thrilling action visually stunning world
building interesting characters social
consciousness cool beans beans but now
that we're hearing that there was
originally a director's cut upwards of 4
hours long it sounds like there are
quite a few deleted scenes that Ryan
Coogler left out of the film so sure
we're stuffed from that great movie but
yeah we can fit in a few more reasons to
love this movie we're obsessed we have
to know everything
so let's break down all of the black
panther deleted scenes okay so the first
alternate concept involved Sheree
originally this movie was going to
feature Sheree getting her own black
panther vibranium suit inspired by
shuri's run in the comics where she
briefly carries the mantle of black
panther concept art for the movie
confirms this idea was definitely being
considered also her neck armor in the
battle with kill monger at the end of
the movie was influenced by these
designs of her own suit there was
another sequence deleted from the film
that showed more of two challahs
relationship with Nakia and the whole
river tribe that she's part of the two
were going to be seeing jogging through
the river tribe region with deshyla
interacting with his ex-girlfriend's
parents instead the final cut more or
less represents the river tribe with its
characters Nakia in the tribes elder
keeping that perspective in the film
without actually setting major sections
of the movie in that part of all conduct
another relationship we're gonna see
more of is the one between a koi a Danai
gurira character and what kabhi daniel
Callejas character now I don't know
about you but at the end of the movie
when Wakaba is charging rhino suddenly
hit the brakes and affectionately licks
a koi a that was a little confused like
huh all right right they're together now
they definitely established their
relationship once earlier in the film
when Takuya a bead times with two chala
and Maccabi and other than that they
really only you know shoot each other
dirty looks occasionally during meetings
like you know those nonverbal glances
that say you are sleeping in the Rhino
stables tonight Ryan Coogler wrote and
shot a whole other scene between these
two to make their relationship have more
of an arc in which they throw down their
conflicting loyalties after kill monger
takes over I suppose kind of like the
scene between a koi a and Nakia that we
saw koogler fought to keep it in the
film but ultimately he's sided with the
producers that at that point the story
the audience just really wants to get to
the conclusion faster and will copies
surrender to a koi yay and that battle
would really be satisfying enough now
Okoye is the primary door malate we get
to see in black pant there
but this movie also features the return
of a Oh played by Florence kizomba she's
the door Malaysia guard at accompany two
chala in Captain America Civil War she's
also gonna return in Avengers infinity
war and earlier drafted the script
actually included a scene with AO in a
coy way that hinted at a flirtatious
relationship between the two women
according to the screenwriter they were
gonna check each other out with one of
them saying you look good and the other
ones saying I know in the comics
AO actually has a romantic relationship
with another female character Aletta who
isn't in this movie this moment with a
coy way might have been a nod to that
moving on to Bucky the Winter Soldier he
was also planned to have a bigger part
of this movie since you know Civil War
really just left him in Wakanda as a toy
for Black Panther to play with probably
the idea was that Bucky was gonna join
two challahs forces in the final battle
to reclaim the throne but the filmmakers
decided against it saying it might feel
a little weird to have this outsider
interfering with what's essentially an
internal wakandan struggle among warring
tribes now sure that's basically
whatever at Ross is doing by gunning
down outgoing wakandan weapon transports
but yeah on the ground beating up border
tribesmen might have just felt a little
awkward in the Black Panther movie as
for this movie's villain at one point
during development the character of
Kraven the hunter from Marvel Comics was
considered to be the villain now he may
have been left out because in the comics
he's more often associated with
spider-man and all those related
characters which if the lawyers were
look into it might have made him more of
a Sony property now after this movie's
actual amazing villain kill monger the
filmmakers had a few ultimate ways to go
with him there was one idea for a scene
where kill monger was going to design
and create his own vibranium suit
instead he just uses the alternate
golden necklace version that was already
in sharees lab there was also some ideas
to try to keep kill monger alive at the
end of the story since you know he's
such a great character but yeah as he
explains to T'Challa after his defeat
kill monger is never a character who
would let himself be imprisoned his
quote that death is better than bondage
is such a powerful way to end his
journey and really underline the
thematic debate at the heart of the film
actually go check out my breakdown for
more of a deeper dive into that stuff
and finally we come to the alternate
ending so as you know the mid-credits
scene of the movie featured two challahs
speaking in front of the UN I was a
little odd for this aim to be revealed
as a sort of surprise considering we saw
pieces of it in trailers and promo
that's because this sequence was
supposed to be the film's original
ending the idea was that two Chawla was
going to end with this high-profile
press conference similar to Tony Stark's
famous press conference at the end of
Ironman
instead Ryan Coogler moved it to the
credit scene slot so that he could end
the film on this scene in Oakland
preferring somethi Matic symmetry with
the opening Oakland scene of the movie
it does always feels better in a story
when the opening and closing shots have
this kind of harmony to suggest how the
story has come full circle and to show
how the world has changed in this case
the Forgotten streets kill mugger grew
up on are now being looked after by a
more responsible role model to Chawla
and the resources of Wakanda and really
Kugler explained that de chala is
essentially doing the same thing in this
Oakland scene as he is at the UN
revealing himself to the world just to
different audiences a question for you
guys would you have preferred to kill
monger to have survived the end of this
movie or did he need to die for this
story to feel complete comment with your
thoughts down below I want to hear what
you think tweet me directly at da vas
and follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos and of course
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of Black Panther again you can
check out my in-depth breakdown for all
the movies Easter eggs and miscible
design details as well as another video
where I analyze the movies amazing
soundtrack and if you really love us and
you want to help us grow you can
contribute to this channel on patreon
big thanks to our donors especially
ponies Stark thanks for watching